often I will tell a mom who's staying at
home with four kids it's very important
that you Mom do what you have to do
during the day when the kids are gone to
take care of
yourself and that is unfortunately you
got to find some places where you can
move your body you got to find some
places where you have some adult women
friends um but I have to have these
things built into my life because what
I'm trying to do is take my water glass
and pour out as much water as I can
before those four kids get home and
start trying to test everything all at
the same time because they're going to
be dumping water into that glass and so
I want it as empty as possible